[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous emmène dans un spot
juste officines plage sable fin
cocotiers pour vous parler d'un produit
super cool pour améliorer vos photos et
vos vidéos avec votre smartphone parce
qu'on a tous des jolies smartphone dans
la poche
on filme tous avec le rendu est souvent
pas mal je pose de très près en même
temps que si ça bouge ccusé mois-ci vous
donne la nausée
le résultat est souvent pas mal mais on
peut faire souvent beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup mieux et aujourd'hui je vous ai
dégoté un petit produit qui nous vient
tout droit de californie la société sans
marque action d'hier et c'est un petit
objectif optique un ca un grand-angle
pour iphone 10 et il est vraiment bien
parce que vous pouvez vraiment amélioré
significativement le contenu deux fois
photos et vos vidéos sur vos appareils
sur votre iphone entre autres vous
invite à regarder cette vidéo jusqu'au
bout parce que il se peut il se peut que
ce produit joue là je dis ça je dis rien
bon je vous explique
c'est une vidéo j'ai tourné quand
j'étais en vacances il ya pas très
longtemps que j'ai gardées sous le coude
pour vous publié aujourd'hui donc je
vous fait voyager un peu je vous ramène
un peu en vacances et ça c'est plutôt
pas mal
est-ce qu'on est pas mal dans ce spot la
regardez moi ça je vous ai réservé un
petit coin de paradis rien pour vous
derrière on a fait ce qu'on voit là le
fameux parachutes ascensionnels histoire
de se marrer un peu sur la côte et on va
donc tester ça alors nous avons besoin
de deux choses la toute première c'est
la boîte du seul marc
chose c'est un iphone 10 parce que l'un
et l'autre vont semble alors on y va on
les assemble effets spéciaux quand tu
nous tiens ça ressemble un peu à ça vous
avez up votre iphone avec une énorme
optique à l'arrière et quand je dis
énorme je pèse vraiment mes mots elle
est juste énorme vous avez un cache là
c'est vraiment un truc qui est juste
complètement énorme alors ça c'est la
boîte pour l'iphone dit c'est à dire que
vous avez votre smartphone là vous avez
votre optique grand angle qui est
complètement dingue
alors vous avez la possibilité soit
d'avoir la coque directement optimisé
pour votre iphone 10 vous venez de
visser dessus donc c'est très solide ça
bosse pas ça tombe pas et fort
heureusement d'ailleurs dont vous filmez
vous fait de très belles choses mais si
vous n'avez pas d'iphone disent vous
avez aussi une solution et qui est super
cool à savoir que le packaging est pas
mal vous avez quand même je vous montre
ses rangées là dedans dans ce petit étui
donc ça c'est super cool ça vient se
dévisser tout naturellement comme ça
derrière vous avez aussi une petite
protection qui est je ne sais plus où
nos chers
et le deuxième point qui est super cool
si vous n'avez pas un iphone 10 mai que
vous avez n'importe quel iphone avec
n'importe quel club comme moi là dessus
vous avez un accessoire vous avez un
accessoire qui est top qui est juste là
regardez c'est une passe comme quoi des
fois et surtout qu'on sa marche
vous allez mettre votre petit dessus
vient la grande
vous avez une vie cela hélas vous vie
c'est ça là dessus et vous venez le
positionner directement en face dans
votre smartphone ça fait là faire ce qui
fait vous pouvez l'utiliser sur
n'importe quel smartphone c'est juste
complètement dingue
et ça change vraiment le truc je vous
filmer avec et sans vous allez voir
c'est hallucinant ce petit accessoire
chance quand même pas mal de choses ça
vous ouvre énormément votre image ça
nous fait quelque chose de beaucoup plus
grand c'est vraiment top
et puis surtout c'est adaptable à tous
types de smartphone donc pas être
lorsqu'on va faire c'est qu'on va faire
une vidéo
on a filmé plein de trucs super cool ici
autour de moi et puis à la fin on fera
un petit débrief ensemble
[Musique]
bah on tourne avec l'objectif justement
de sang de marque qui a le printemps rue
et qui est super cool donc là vous voyez
même temps et là ya pas de grand-angle
et franchement c'est pas la même chose
[Musique]
je viens qu'une fois de plus de péter
fong sai bonne idée d'acheter des trucs
pourris ici le chien bear ont cuit voilà
pour cette vidéo de test de cette
optique si elle vous intéresse bien
évidemment que j'ai mis un lire la
description et comme vous êtes gentil je
vous gâte cette optique je vous l'offre
voilà merci ne me remerciez pas pour la
gagne et c'est très simple vous donne
rendez vous sur twitter monsieur greu ou
alors une deuxième chance sur ay d'itv
instagram monsieur underscore e vous
avez tous les liens dans la description
et une fois sur place vous expliquerai
comment participer et comment gagner la
vôtre vous allez voir c'est génial parce
qu'avec ça vous allez pouvoir filmer sur
tous types de smartphones améliorer
vraiment vos photos et vos vidéos et ça
c'est juste top merci à vous une fois de
plus des toujours plus nombreux shows
plus nombreux sur la chaîne je vous
invite à rester connectés
bien évidemment si ce projet vous
intéresse je dis galiana description ya
le concours pour gagner donc rester une
fois de plus puis vous allez voir il ya
plein de choses qui vont arriver dans
les temps à venir les choses super cool
donc ça c'est vraiment génial merci à
vous je vous dis à très bientôt un pu
marquer mais bien sûr tous vos
commentaires questions suggestions
directement tout ce que vous voulez en
bas comme ça on discute ensemble c'est
génial c'est cool je vous embrasse avec
une petite bise de fin de vacances ou et
puis vous laisse regarder le point de
vue parce que c'est quand même la plus
jolie sitôt
[Musique]